the subjects for which we got the most
letters and phone calls and overall
response on alternative use are the
programs involving john stockwell and
the CIA and Gary Shaw regarding the
Kennedy assassination well hold on to
your seats folks this is a special
occasion because we have both of these
gentlemen with us on alternative views
Gary Shaw of course is the author of
cover up he's been studying the Kennedy
assassination for the last 25 years and
undoubtedly you've seen our two previous
or maybe three previous programs with
Gary Shaw john stockwell of course was
in the CIA for 13 years got out wrote
his famous book in search of enemies and
we've done all I know anywhere from 35
to 40 programs with John well on
alternative views now we're going to
look at the Kennedy assassination from
the aspect of putting together trying to
put together the conspiracy to kill John
Kennedy in our previous programs we've
demolished the Warren Commission report
so we're not even going to deal with
that
today but we're going to try to
reassemble if we can the whole
conspiracy very complex operation and
then also look at the cover-up that took
place because that was quite an
operation - there also been a lot of
books that have been written recently
about the Kennedy assassination and
we're going to review those as well so
this I I don't want to take any more
time with introduction I'm so excited
about what we're going to be talking
about
well Gary let's begin with your thesis
of what actually happened let's try to
reconstruct step by step your analysis
of how the assassination of John F
Kennedy took place that fateful day in
Dallas how long that's going to take
this dug we'll we'll try yeah what are
the different elements in this
conspiracy
basically the
different elements and the conspiracy
concern the politics of that day John
Kennedy's movement in certain directions
that were contrary in some aspects to
almost every major force in America and
so though he was a very popular
president with the majority of the
people he had made an awful lot of very
powerful folks mad at him and so Texas
was having its problems from the
Democratic Party standpoint and they
were divided and so the president comes
to Texas on a political trip and they
plan motorcades and so forth for him to
meet the people give speeches and try to
mend those party wounds he arrives in
Dallas and is of course assassinated
we're told by one lone individual
anybody was that was there you
immediately that there were more than
one gunman but there were several in
fact we've got certain eyewitnesses that
fella felt like that there was an
automatic weapon being used
that's how forceful and how quickly the
shots were being fired at the motorcade
so what I did is exactly the opposite of
what the Warren Commission did not do
and that is take the evidence from that
day that we had the physical evidence
and and try to make some sense of it and
go backward from the scene of the crime
and establish shooters placement of the
shooters gone directions number of shots
etc and in doing so it was real easy to
determine that there were at least four
primary gunmen to to the president's
front right front and remember in the
motorcade the clear side of the
automobile is the right in the rear they
planned it perfectly and so there were
two shooters to the right front two
shooters to the right rear the ones in
the front were more on a level with the
motorcade
two in the rear were upward and above
this limited in the possibility of
hurting people within the limousine
wounding others in fact to some extent
this was this would have required so
much coordination so much planning that
so many people would have to have been
involved of starting even you know with
the route that it was taken it's correct
whoever designed the route either had to
been involved in the conspiracy or the
conspirators would have had to know the
route sufficiently in advance to be able
to plan it and to be able to train on a
previous program you said you think they
probably trained with mock-ups and all
of this now can you give us an idea of
how this might have taken place okay I
believe it's very simple I think that
not necessarily did they have to have
the someone to plan the motorcade route
I think they knew in advance from people
that they had contact with the direction
of the motorcade would take and from
that they were able to plan the best
possible site for it they chose this
site and they practiced with it
I think they built a mock-up they they
had there to kill zones okay this is the
kill zone a I call this gunman number
one and gunman number two it's a
triangulation of gunfire very
strategically located let's say I point
one is that on top on top of the School
Book Depository okay okay this is the
final two shots that hit the president
this isn't kill Zone B are the 630 Road
stripes and comes from the southwestern
Lea sixth floor window of the School
Book Depository and from the picket
fence just above the grassy knoll to the
left that's number three and number four
it's real important for us to take
another look at this a pruder film this
is the famous Abraham Zapruder film of
the Kennedy assassination
the president is now hit in the back
then while he's behind the sign he's hit
in the throat from the front he's not
grasping at his throat and trying to
talk to his wife and the fatal head shot
this is a blow up of that head shot
the president has hit now trying to talk
to his wife and he receives the fatal
head shot the president's reaction to
the head shot can be seen more clearly
with these enlargements notice that as
the prison is struck by the fatal head
shot his body is driven violently
backwards and if you watch the Zapruder
film you see the president hit twice at
one section of the street he's hit again
twice at a section the second section he
just happened to coincide with the
fourth set of road stripes numbering
down from Houston Street on him to the
sixth set of Road stripes that was
pre-planned they didn't have to try to
follow him when he came to that sixth
set of road stripes there's two gunmen
that were already honed in right at that
point and they didn't have to have much
timing between the two because they knew
where they were going to hit him and
they they fired
they did their job the one thing you
don't want to do if you're going to kill
the president of the United States or
any leader is miss and I think they had
two teams two shooters
shooting teams and they very accurately
did their job that they how far ahead
would an elaborate assassination like
this have to have been planned and have
the people contacted to do it and
trained so that they would be able to do
such an incredibly perfect job when they
when the time came this is going to lead
us into a slightly different related
subject inside the CI you don't have a
class on assassinations in training you
don't rehearse assassinations in fact
they work very hard to convince you that
the CIA doesn't do assassinations and
then later on and your career as it
happened with me you begin to learn that
they do but there is no book in the CIA
or SOP or file or office that teaches
assassinations they would lose the magic
of the CIA if there were which is the
plausible deniability
of having so many employees who are
slightly naive good soldiers who believe
it's clean organization and then you
compartment out things like the
assassination and like the drug
experimentation program and the disease
experimentation program from my military
background putting it in terms of an
ambush see that but which I think it was
they planned it they executed it like a
military ambush and this is what leads
me to the conclusion and I think other
researchers in the direction the the
shooting itself having been planned
rehearsed and executed by principally
the opie mongoose CI group in florida
that was training for raids into cuba
they had the training facilities they
had the expertise they had combat
experience in cuba and it doesn't ring
to me like a mob hit
no the execution oh it was military and
then taking it from from that looking at
it as a military ambush you could do it
very quickly you could do it in a couple
of three weeks and do a good job of it
if you have Pro seasoned pros
it seems to me reading the books and the
history of what happened they were
probably working on the ambush itself
for perhaps four months they probably
were mapping out where they were going
to do it and setting up the mock-ups
during the summer that would be my guess
okay so that was just a part of the
conspiracy we have the Oswald factor and
the fake Oswald or the other Oswald's
how many ever Oswald's there were now
some people believe that Oswald was part
of the conspiracy people some people say
he wasn't some people say he actually
fired shots some say didn't but whether
he did or not the name and person Oswald
or people Oswald was involved in a very
careful planning it looked to me because
we had Oswald showing up in Mexico City
we had Oswald
here a man named Oswald going from Miami
to Dallas in a caravan carrying rifles
you mentioned a previous program that a
and international I think was sweater
and international killer who also used
the name of Oswald no it was a fellow
from Texas young man from Texas that
used the name Oswald and his gun-running
operation okay that's what people
challenged that so there would have had
to have been this planning ahead of time
also either to have Oswald as the Patsy
or to have all these other various ways
of set up to try to make somebody the
Patsy so what is your feeling on this
aspect of a conspiracy I think naturally
in in the pre-planning of this thing
they had to have something that would
throw the authorities off there in
Dallas immediately and oz will became
convenient because of his background as
having been communist to lie and he went
to Russia and announced his citizenship
and so forth and he was a perfect one
because let's face it in the United
States and in Texas we're ready to hate
a little commie any day of the week you
know and so when they were able to pick
up Havel and he had good background he
had already been working with the Cuban
exiles we found out he was also working
as a pro Castro right and passing out
fair play for Cuba leaflets and etc so
he would seem like a cover-up itself
that's right he's doing all of the right
things and his trip to Mexico is a
mystery it's still a mystery after 25
years and we still don't know what he
was doing we do know this again the CIA
John plays a particular role in this
that I still don't understand that is
that they had cameras monitoring the
Cuban embassy and the Russian embassy 24
hours a day
front and back doors I mean I think in
Mexico City and yet they were never able
to produce photographs and this was film
work you know they produced photographs
of other individuals and even a man who
identified himself as Lee Henry Oswald
but never were they able to produce a
photograph when asked about it they said
the camera happened to be broken the
three days that he was not there you
know so I I don't know what to make of
that
I do feel like if if the real Oswald had
done what the Warren Commission and the
CIA and the FBI FBI said that he did in
Mexico City that they would have had
photographs and they would have pasted
them on the front of every newspaper in
the world and because he was going down
there again wanting to go to Cuba get a
visa to go to Cuba so that he could go
back to the USSR but don't many people
think that that was the other Oswald
that went to Mexico City that was a dupe
or a double again you've got conflict
you've got you've got his signature on
hotel records that the handwriting
experts say are his you've got
eyewitnesses saying that the man that
identified himself is Oswald was not the
man they show they saw shoot Jack Ruby
on television and his picture appeared
in the newspapers so you've got again
those conflicts that have never been
reconciled and we've not done it yet I
assume was it possible that the CIA or
me maybe the FBI with the CIA has people
who are so good at copying that they can
sign somebody's name and it'll look
exactly like this here they must have so
to have a receipt with Oswald's name on
it could fool an expert if somebody
wanted one possible scenario is that
they send Oswell down to Mexico City
without him knowing what he was doing
I had some operation he thought he was
part of to get him in the hotels and
having a straightest in the scene then
they have their other person go in
pretending to be Oswald in the embassy
and they don't have any photographs you
know conveniently no the cameras were
broken that day and so there's nothing
to disprove that it was Oz well he went
into the embassy what what they came up
with though that seemed to contradict it
pretty flatly was the testimony of the
Cuban consul and the people in the
office who said you know as a the guy
was three inches taller and totally
different build and appearance that's
one possible scenario again we can't we
can't prove it the way I see this thing
working trying to make it understandable
to me as I knew the agency and the
people in the halls who people like
myself and Ralph McGehee for example
would Phil lychee would never you know
have remained in an organization that
killed the president I mean we were we
were patriotic you know and we were
supporting the system and the president
was the commander in chief and yet the
organization clearly was involved so you
think of it in terms of compartment
ation you have this group down in
Florida which is not inside the building
bureaucrats you know wearing coats and
ties and shuffling papers pretty well
people a lot of them Cuban exiles and
passionately involved taking chances
with their lives
going into Cuba killing people and
blending smoothly into the mob
activities into Cuba and if they were
the ones that did it as appears to be
the case
they were quite compartmented from the
activities and the building and all the
rest of us then you start saying well
how broad was the conspiracy and I
suggest that it could have worked this
way it wouldn't take that many people to
actually plan and execute the killing
including setting up Oswald as a decoy
as a patsy for the simple reason if you
take a total of 10 to 12 people there at
the time of the ambush
Jack Ruby undoubtedly involved in
running errands working with them and
maybe a couple of other people in New
Orleans in Houston directed by the O P
Mongoose connections from Florida and
you could do everything you know that I
see having been done you do have to have
some kind of cooperation from the Secret
Service to detour the presidential
convoy this might have been full
complicity by the Secret Service or it
might have been someone led into it and
a gross lack of discipline which we've
seen the Secret Service manifest many
times before in the past but to make it
work on a broader scale to cover-up you
had to have an atmosphere where a broad
segment of the government and the mob
had agreed that somebody ought to kill
the bastard is you know they saw it and
each segment that was involved in the
cover-up had to have their own grievance
against them but the president which
they did so one they were hearing rumors
that it was going to happen to an
atmosphere had been created were they
condoned in advance that it would happen
it was okay to kill this president they
were kind of hungry for it happen so you
have a relatively small group of people
actually plan and execute the killing
and a bunch of other people standing by
and just automatically saying it's an
iron turist WorkCover up on it and they
had been fed some essential ingredients
that would make a cover-up possible on
which to build a cover-up that seems to
us in retrospect to have been pretty
preposterous of a lone assassin very
small police force with limited
resources would in a serious
investigation would immediately have
turned up a hundred things that were not
consistent with a lone assassin but just
by throwing out the lone assess and they
were able to seize on that and build on
that rather flagrantly but successfully
to sell it to the public in such a way
and he established the rest of the
establishment so that no one was ever
punished but John that sounds a lot like
the book betrayal by Robert Morrow in
which he tries to reconstruct as best he
could
and he said that it was done with a
renegade group of CIA people in
conjunction with the Cuban exiles but
with the knowledge of the CIA up the top
let it happen it was done by these
people but someone up at the top had to
know but see that doesn't mean whole
building or all 15,000 people had to
know but there had to be a thread going
up to the top and I've speculated a lot
you know who who was the chain how high
does it go a lot of things seem to
indicate that dick Helms probably knew
of it and may have been involved in
prior approvals and planning or he may
have been sitting there knowing sensing
that it was going on but in the sense
you do a lot of things in the CIA
without spelling it out headquarters
they teach you to do that what you don't
put in writing and the whole science of
being a chief of station is to know what
they want done and to make it happen but
without forcing them to say yes or no
and of course where it gets tricky is if
you miss read them and do something they
don't want done you can wreck your whole
career so that's the subtlety of that
business so you can have these people in
Florida planning this thing Helms
knowing that it was going to happen but
no one having put him you know on the
spot where he would have to say yes or
no or sign something and then it happens
he clearly participated in the cover-up
oh how was Helms said that was he
director at that time in the director
deputy deputy director our previous
programs you indicated that you thought
there were some foreign professional
assassins particularly Frenchmen
involved in this or a Frenchman now that
they brought in to do the job and they
got him out the next day now is this how
does this coincide with John's thesis
that it was the Cuban exiles and their
operation there among this conglomerate
this group of people that were
participating in being trained by the
CIA were mercenaries or soldiers of
fortune from from the corners of the
world and it was not unusual to find
Frenchmen Belgians mercenaries and so
forth
so it would not surprise me if you're
going to kill the most important man in
the world at that time and I seem is
that I think you would get the best
trained men available and it does not
surprise me that the evidence leads
toward some French mercenaries being
being used in this operation III don't
have any great problem with that but I
don't think that they necessarily had to
have brought in a full team of shooters
from Marseille for the simple reason
they had some very passionate people
right on their own stats I could
visualize a scene where some of the
people like Rolando Bosch was saying I
want to shoot when I want one of the
rifles and maybe some of the others but
they might have had a professional or
two brought in you know as the nucleus
of the thing is there a mafia connection
that's plausible to the two of you it is
to me simply because the mob was already
operating within this this program the
operations is to the operation Mongoose
and and they had taken two of your
high-ranking mafia figures Johnny
Roselli and Sam Giancana the Kennedys
had gone after them that's right the
mobs one of its big bases of operations
was in Havana before the Revolution and
Fidel was cutting all that off severing
the ties of nationalizing the gambling
casinos that had belonged to Trafficante
and other mob figures and so in the wart
the efforts to kill Fidel had been begun
by the mob before the see I approached
the mob and said let's kill Castro for
example the mob operations and
activities into Cuba were extensive and
this put them shoulder-to-shoulder and
piggybacking upon and working with the
CIA on goofs people and decubitus to
some points where they you know it's
almost indistinguishable you know as to
what where does CI activity stop and mob
activities start these are the the
operations from Florida and to Cuba one
example it's not crystal clear but it
does make a point as this David Ferrie
the pilot
was clearly at times flying arms for the
CIA also allegedly flew Marcelo back
from Guatemala where Bobby Kennedy had
had him thrown out of the country and he
flew back in an apparent now the
question is was theory on the mob
payroll when he flew Marcelo back in or
did the CIA sent him to get Marcelo and
bringing back in but you take it another
step of course the famous Jack Ruby is
whose ties are so extent this may have
nothing to do with anything but in 1947
congressman Richard Nixon intervened
when the Congress was investigating Jack
Rubenstein in Chicago and got him off
from from being investigated and he
relocated to Dallas and became Jack Ruby
Nixon had extensive close relationships
with the Mafia so close that I according
to the Playboy history of organized
crime the Secret Service had to say hey
Richard you better cool it you can't
keep going out on yachts with these guys
they're mafia people going to start
looking at this clearly a liability and
his presidency getting into the detail
and there's several of these these books
that are out now where you can read the
contract on America particularly in some
of the others about the mob activities
in Dallas and how extensive they were
bringing back to what we were talking
about before the set up luring the
president into the ambush was the Secret
Service involved to my knowledge we
don't know but we do know the Secret
Service people out boozing it up until
5:00 in the morning one of them in a
nightclub that was owned by a friend of
Jack Ruby's the night before the
assassin it was spring close friend of
Jack Ruby's a place where Jack Ruby I
ran you know visited and hung out same
girls worked there same girls work there
and they were there some of them until
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and one
until 5:00 in the morning this is the
president Secret Service now again it
could just be a very very dirty sloppy
Secret Service operation and they're
hung over and that might explain alone
some of their very dubious
unprofessional conduct during the
shooting you know basic rule when the
bullets started flying mash down
the accelerator and get out of there and
instead the driver stopped and turned
around and looked back for a while for
some very precious seconds that could
just be people with with heavy hangovers
or it could be some corruption from the
mob or maybe the mobs roll was just take
these people out and show them a good
time and get them thoroughly drunk
provide information also to indeed CIA
or whoever the hitman were so you don't
think the mob were part of the hit squad
in other words it has more of a military
CIA operation oh I think they over left
right into AZ yeah I think I think that
the lines distinguishing from the
Mongoose people in their activities and
the mob activities and in Florida and
New Orleans and Dallas through Ruby were
probably indistinguishable Ferry working
for both Jack Ruby working for both and
distinguished blend you get into the
question about how would they know what
the route exact route was well you know
if if if they're boozing it up until
5:00 in the morning with Secret Service
baby you can presume that the contact
was very intimate intimate and I knew a
lot about what was happening there's
always been something that has not
bothered me but just puzzled me a bit
how far ahead of time did Oswald take
that job at the school book depository
hmm about a month there's about a month
little over a mom myself he was part of
the conspiracy they would have had to
know what the route was a month ahead of
time whether or not if they were going
to plant him as the Patsy and I wonder
even if they if the trip was scheduled
that far in advance yes the trip was
planned that far in advance and probably
the motorcade was on paper and the the
one key ingredient there too to knowing
about the motorcade is Jack Ruby's close
relationship with the Dallas Police
Department he went as he pleased among
them they came to his club they were
treated royally his girls were towed to
wine dine whatever they needed and to
take care of them that's the reason he
was able on Friday night we even have
one witness now a policeman whose office
was right next door
were to where they were interrogating
Oswald who said that Jack Ruby on Friday
night actually went into the office of
will Fritz where they were interrogating
Oswald we know he was at the police he
we've got film of him but that didn't
ever come out and this is a reliable
officer of that day who's now retired
and says I don't care this needs to be
known the route then but that is
selected by the local police or the
Secret Service or selected by the local
police and then approved by the Secret
Service because it was against all
regulations basically the record is this
that the Secret Service were taken by
Assistant Chief Charles Batchelor at the
time who was in charge of the motorcade
when Batchelor got to Dealey Plaza after
driving the first part of the motorcade
and he said then we hit Stemmons freeway
right up here and it's right out to
Market Hall he did not tell the Secret
Service that there would be a right-hand
turn going down Houston 90-degree
right-hand turn and then that 120 degree
angle turn down on Elm Street he did not
take him that far
so you can speculate either that we
don't want to know
don't tell us anything or they were not
told anything and they assumed that they
would continue right on directly at Main
Street at main stream the street tied
into Stemmons freeway and once again you
either say this is part of the
conspiracy or this is part of the people
who are incredibly incompetent but you
find this all the way through so that
all the way which leads me to ask the
question about the FBI then there seem
to be complicity with the FBI
particularly in the cover-up but now is
the conspiracy there were people
flashing badges Secret Service badges
FBI badges here and there maybe they
were fake maybe they weren't but what
was then the extent of the FBI
relationships I've heard people say that
Oswald had relationships with the FBI
and Ruby of course had relationship
there was an early report that Oswell
had an informant status with the FBI
they had an informant number that he
received funds monthly one of the
Western Union people to testify to that
fact and that he received $200 a month
and his informant number was like this -
170 - in other words they get real
specific now what I have a tendency to
believe is that probably another
individual was this informant who was
using the name
Oswald and was working for the FBI and
so they could legitimately say Lee
Harvey Oswald the man who shot the
president was never an informative iris
but this other man who was being used
and I think all of the evidence points
to some type of either Bureau
involvement or intelligence involvement
even if it's a lower echelon involvement
of Lee Harvey Oswald every I mean it's
like Senator Swiper said the
fingerprints of intelligence are on
every move that he made back in that
period of time FBI or CIA one of the
other or defense intelligence agents who
read a number and so that's kind of the
way I have approached it it does not
have to be and the FBI had already
destroyed a note you know that the
Oswald had brought up there on Oswald do
you think he was a patsy or a
participant my best guess is that he had
absolutely nothing to do with the
shooting that day I think the evidence
would prove that out in a court of law
but there was somebody in his place who
look very much like him and it's even a
good possibility that house will acting
on behalf of one of these agencies had
actually knew about the plot
and perhaps it even tried to report it
mark Lane gave a speech in which he said
that when Oswald was informed that
Kennedy and Machat he said so and they
were accusing him of doing it he said so
I'm the Patsy right now which would lead
me to believe that he was part of the
conspiracy he may not have fired he may
not have been at the School Book
Depository and all but it leads you to
think that he was part of the conspiracy
or part of something john davis rota
wrote a book called mafia kingfish it'll
be out in paperback in in November and I
urge your viewers to divide look it did
does make a very good case for Carlos
Marcello as the the force is one of the
forces behind the assassination of
President but he uncovered evidence that
Lee Harvey Oswald actually worked for
the Marcelo family in New Orleans as a
boy supposedly as a runner on his his
uncle did work for Marcelo they know
that and he worked for his for his uncle
and so that's a close tie with New
Orleans and with David Ferrie and with
you know organized crime and when it
came time to to find somebody as this
Patsy he was a natural which leads me to
the conclusion that whoever his
immediate superior his case officer or
whoever it might be that the directed
his activities in whatever intelligence
operation that he was in had to have
also probably been in on the conspiracy
to kill the president and he was
manipulating Lee Harvey Oswald into the
position that he was the job at the
Texas School Book Depository his trip
back to his rooming house where the
Dallas police car while he's inside
comes up in honks twice and he comes out
in the last time the landlady sees him
he's standing on the corner waiting on a
bus and then the next thing you know
ticket is killed and hostel is way over
in if the timing is impossible for him
to have done all of these things but he
ends up in the theater with a gun
you know and is arrested the the first
two things the cops say to me and here
is a man miles from the scene of a crime
they have absolutely no indication that
he's done anything other than allegedly
sneaked into a theater without paying
and they arrested him and they're saying
shoot the president with you we have
eyewitnesses near witnesses testifying
to that that's what they were saying
even to the point of taking a gun book
and striking with it
and at that point they didn't have any
of the reconstructions of the Warren
Commission which turns out to be
stretched and false and so they had to
been all set up with stories that Oswell
was the person to go after and that he
had killed the president on that well
now were these people part of the
conspiracy or did somebody tip them off
some on the scene and say okay there is
get in power
well I think you know this is
speculation and can be discounted as
such but I was when he saw what came
down immediately would do what I would
do John would do and he calls his
superior and says hey this has happened
what's going on and he says I don't know
meet me at the Texas theater like we
usually do or meet me at Mar say Zoo
whatever they decide is a meeting place
and then they hang up he picks up the
phone he calls the authorities your man
will be such and such play such and such
time there is another aspect of the
conspiracy which either put them needed
to be taken care of or as part of the
cover-up which we'll get into later and
that's the medical aspect there were
medical people all along the line and
there's one whole book written about it
that destroyed evidence tampered with
evidence messed around with evidence so
how did the was this part of the
conspiracy to that people had to have
their counterparts or people working
with them and the medical flow of this
from Dallas on it through Washington I
think there's no doubt that there had to
be and I think it had to come basically
from from within the the White House the
one man who was key to all of this was
Admiral George Burkley the president's
chief physician he was with the
president at Parkland Hospital he was
with him on Air Force One he was with
him at the at the autopsy and he ordered
the autopsy surgeons at that pie at that
point not to do certain things very
valuable thing like not to probe the
back one so that they could determine
its track and therefore the direction
and an angle of the shot not to probe
the throat when certain things had been
done to the president's body
Henry hurt and this is gone missed by
most people Henry hurt called dr.
Berkley and dr. Berkley said yes there
was a conspiracy this was this was in
1975 and he he indicated that he would
be willing to talk to mr. hurt when this
hurt got back to him he was very angry
very adamant and said I will not talk
forget I ever said anything and that is
in his book though but and he has got it
on recording his original statement is
yes that there was a conspiracy they
would have had to start right at
Parkland Hospital because that's a red
magic bullet the pristine bullet that
did all the damage but came out with a
without a trace a remark on it that was
found on a stretcher so it had to have
been the medical aspect should have
would have had to start there as far as
the cover-up because I was in the
military control operation complete and
I think you've got to ask yourself the
question if you know if this happened
how would Robert Kennedy fit into this
why would why would he keep his mouth
shut
etc and we learned probably about six or
seven years ago that to one of the first
people that Robert Kennedy called
was wearing one of the very top Cuban
exile leaders a fella by the name of
Harry Rhys Williams that's Harry RI
rui-zi I believe Rhys Williams and he
told him that hey one of your guys
killed the president and that's not a
pro-castro act that's an anti-castro and
you have to ask yourself well why didn't
our Bert do something about it I think
immediately they realized that the same
group went to Dallas that they were
sending to Cuba and when they realized
that and realized that those tracks
would come right back to them they had
they had to say stop we've got to cut
this off now and they did do that I look
to clarify that they the nd in that case
being they in that case Robert Kennedy
the people in in the White House dr.
Burke leader orders directly to dr.
Berkley I think J Edgar Hoover and the
Central Intelligence Agency had already
seen what would happen if I think and so
they they chose the lone assassin the
cover-up had to have begun before the
assassination setting up as well as a
patsy was prior planning and that a
pristine bullet in the hospital the
bullet had to have been prepared and
someone had it there to drop it on the
site
Hoover apparently began to give orders
the same day you know that they should
focus on a lone assassin and you know
prove he did it so he was clearly poised
to react in a certain way he didn't have
to take a couple of days to think about
which way it was going to fall and take
you know an expedient solution he had a
position on it beginning immediately he
had Kennedy Robert Kennedy his position
it's you know he was disempowered
the bullets started flying in Dallas to
all practical purposes his power was his
brother the president his brother is
killed Johnson is the president Bobby
Kennedy lost his power base at that
point it seems to me he was obviously
very bright and he'd been riding himself
in playing hardball for a long time he
obviously knew the risks of this
Vendetta he was waging against organized
crime he must have thought about his own
vulnerability and his brothers and it
seems to me he immediately began okay
get my head down and emerge eventually
as president and then I'll resume the
fight with some muscle to make it happen
and this is the only way I can explain
why he was so relatively quiet about
what had happened he knew he could be
knocked off unless he became president
and had the power to do something about
it
the whole Kennedy family including John
Kennedy's immediate family bought the
lone assassin thing
well they publicly they I really want to
see Albert did I doubt it I doubt it
you could not be an intelligent person
and buy into that thing is it as it
unfolded no I mean but this is part of
the cover-up to it you know put this
face before the American people before
we get into the cover-up I'm not sure
we're going to have time to get into
that maybe we have to wait to the next
program for this but getting back to
this conspiracy we're talking about an
enormous well-planned conspiracy with
people and the Secret Service perhaps in
the medical arenas local police the mob
the CIA the FBI how was it possible or
maybe I'm just not Eve how is it
possible to conceive of an hour to
organized and coordinates such an
enormous conspiracy which required so
much coordination and good timing and
security we I don't see it as having
been a secure operation at all there
were leaks from top and bottom and
sideways and all over the place I think
they use the sledgehammer approach to
the thing one what made the cover-up
work was this broad consensus a huge and
powerful segment of the government the
establishment that it would be okay to
kill a president so a team of people did
it others knew it was going to happen
you know a group went out and and did it
who exactly up high ordered them to or
just knew it was going to happen one can
only speculate but they started killing
us a skilling potential witnesses very
quickly whistleblowers people who had
different contradictory bits and pieces
of the thing very quickly and the word
gets out pretty fast if you're in a
situation like that and witnesses are
dying
eventually according to high treason
book they count forty nine people that
they name who were involved in one way
or another who died violent or
mysterious death and then they allude to
seven more here and seven more there so
a lot of people dying and the military
putting its for example in the medical
establishment the autopsy all of this
done and in military facilities the
military putting the word down that
anyone broke ranks and spoke out would
be court-martialed and then you have a
certain complicity from the press lots
of stuff published about it but
essentially the press eventually went
along with the cover-up and began to
feed and play and support the lone
assassin theory so it wasn't secure at
all there were people all over the place
talking about it but the establishment
decided they were going to buy the
cover-up and cooperate with it and kill
people who could have blown it wide open
the Warren Commission of course was
flagrant and heavy-handed but in effect
successful its selection of witnesses
for example as it as it reworked the
evidence around the autopsy in the body
not calling any of the nurses are
doctors in Dallas to go up and testify
and say where the wounds were and what
the condition of the body was when they
examined it for example this narrowed it
down to fewer doctors that they could
absolutely control that they could put
on the stand and they could easily be
intimidated some of them were quiet
and they've begun to speak out now and
say this is not possible but in your
best guess is the scenario that happened
who actually shot JFK and who actually
was behind it basically you go back to
the politics of that day and John
Kennedy was doing things in Cuba that
had angered organized crime to the
extent that he had made promises that
they'd have the Cubans would have a
battle back which meant the casinos
would open back up prostitution would
flourish the Las Vegas off the coast of
Florida would be blossoming again and
narcotics traffic would have it's easy
flow and and the good times would be
back he reneged on that promise he
reneged at the Bay of Pigs and alienated
the Cuban exiles to the point of bitter
hatred you read books like Peter Wyden's
Bay of Pigs and and you see that they
say if it had a gun and could have
gotten to him that it killed him that
day that the air support didn't come in
now at the pigs bay invasion so you see
that little group and you see that they
have already got in operation an
assassination apparatus they had
documented eight attempts on Fidel
Castro from this CIA group Fidel Castro
says there's 24 I think and the curious
that only took one attempt for president
United only two things that you wonder
how serious these attempts really work
but you you take that grouping right
there and when John Kennedy renege on
everything that he said after the
Missile Crisis and he promised but in a
Khrushchev that there would be and never
been an invasion of Cuba if they'd pull
those offensive missiles out then the
handwriting I think was on the wall at
that time and there was been spinus
involved there was money involved
power and that turned an apparatus that
it was already trained and in in
operation and turned it to to Dallas I
think you've got to remember that we
don't protect or didn't protect our
president at that time like Fidel Castro
was protecting yes I like Charles de
Gaulle was predicted and it was you know
it was a turkey shoot in Dallas yeah the
attempts on Fidel's life were certainly
serious but you had a different
operational problem if you will to try
to do it in Cuba where you did not have
a broad consensus of it's okay to kill
the man that you had in Dallas that you
had in the United States against Kennedy
at that time so they were having to plan
a truly clandestine assassination in
which the the shooter wouldn't have some
kind of magic immunity and a Warren
Commission what not there would be an
extremely vigilant reaction from Fidel's
bodyguard in the Cuban government and
whatnot so they were trying to think of
esoteric clever tricky ways to do it
and Dallas God knows they could set up a
big broad ambush right broad daylight
and gun the man down
you have the killing apparently
engineered by a paramilitary team an
ambush perhaps a small bunch of people
with a few supporters in New Orleans and
Dallas actually engineered the hit
others knowing about it but the cover-up
brings a lot of other very powerful and
big groups into the conspiracy and so
then you get into motive you know why
would the CIA be down on Kennedy enough
to want to kill him and you had it scary
said the Bay of Pigs which they consider
to be a betrayal objective readers in
history would not necessarily create but
they certainly did and also he was in
the policy of reformulating the the
policies in Cuba to actually withdraw
and cutback and curtail the
assassination attempts on Fidel and
break up the opie Mongoose
infrastructure that was raiding and
attacking and Cuba you get this in the
betrayal book by Bob Mora for example
then you have the right-wing military
that you see the you know why did the
military suppress the evidence and
doctor the photographs and control the
doctors their anger could easily have
been because you know a liberal
president pulling them back from with
Vietnam which was designated as their
next big war so the right-wing military
very angry about his position towards
the world and towards war and towards
their choice of wars again the mob the
Kennedy brothers were waging especially
Bobby but with Jack's support were
waging a major vendetta against mob
leaders they put HOF in jail they had
kicked Marcelo out of the country and
then Rosalie and Jim Connie were
incorporated into the activities the mob
had a fight for survival on its hands
with the Kennedys and and then of course
you have their huge investment in Cuba
and then you also have linkage into
Southeast Asia traffic auntie had been
to visit Vietnam they were obviously
planning a shift in resources or the
goat to the Golden Triangle if the US
went in in a big way you'd have lots of
vehicles airplanes and ships literally
that you could piggyback the drugs back
into the states and Kennedy's pulling
out of Southeast Asia the the Texas the
right-wing business folks of course the
oil depletion allowances Kennedy was
cutting them they'd become fabulously
rich from these things and they didn't
want them cut and then you get of course
the key is the FBI not necessarily in
the planning of the killing or the
execution of the killing but certainly
Hoover's position immediate position and
the cover-up was essential to make it
work all his agents trying to construct
our order to try to construct the
evidence that would pinpoint a lone
assassin some of them came up with bits
and pieces that were quite contradictory
which the Warren Commission pretty much
just ignored so where did the FBI come
up with it's big grievance against
Kennedy and this is where you get into
for example contract on America David
shines book Hoeber had and also this
other excellent book we have a copy here
secrecy and power the life of j edgar
Hoover
Hooper had a lifetime association with
organized crime he bet in gambled you
know weekly it was his big passion and
he took two vacations a year regularly
where the bills were picked up by people
who related to organized crime and he
maintained throughout that that
organized crime was not a problem not a
factor in our society didn't exist
didn't exist though the Mafia the
mahkumat didn't exist and so he's in a
position if you know from that position
in that history in that involvement his
relationship with the mob and then of
course his his hard right wing stance
period across the board what you had all
of these people faced with a very
dynamic effective liberal president who
promised to be in office for four years
and then four more years quite possibly
followed by his brother for four years
and maybe four more years and God knows
Teddy after that I mean they could see a
real dinette dynasty I'm moving all the
polls are showing that they had no
chance whatsoever to win in the
electoral process and this is the
reasoning where people come up and say
it was a coup d'etat this right-wing
shadow government faced with you know
each one with their each element with
their grievance against Kennedy and
this.bottom underlying agreement that he
was a liberal you know doing everything
wrong from their view of the world
wanting to get rid of him they couldn't
wait for an election they wouldn't win
an election anyway so the only way they
could defend their interests would be to
eliminate him thereby at the same time
establishing very clearly to subsequent
presidents and senators and
congresspeople
about who really controls the power in
this country and what the bottom line is
when you start taking positions that
could damage their interest
well we've talked about the conspiracy
our next program we're going to talk
about the cover-up and also some of the
new books that have come out recently
with john stockwell and Gary Shaw be
with us I can't wait for that one either
so stay with us for our next program
this is the second in our two-part
series of our continuing series of
studying the Kennedy assassination our
last program was with john stockwell
former CIA official and Gary Shaw author
of cover-up we talked mainly about the
nature of the conspiracy to kill John F
Kennedy this very complex conspiracy
that took place well on the program this
time we're going to talk mainly about
the cover-up and how that has continued
to today until today except on for a lot
of books and speaking of books a lot of
books have been written recently we're
going to review some of these books who
is actually involved in the cover-up and
what steps did it take the cover-up had
to be initiated early on in other words
it had to be pre-planned
for instance if you're going to plant
certain evidence to to point the finger
of guilt to a party or an individual
then that evidence needs to be
manufactured ahead of time and so
probably this was done when the site was
chosen the alleged Patsy was was chosen
and the modus operandi was was all
chosen and picked out and so forth and
early on they had done that the cover-up
actually went into place at the time of
the shooting and that we find that
there's conflicting testimony concerning
the way the alleged sniper's nest
appeared at the time it was found and
and and later on in fact we have at
least four and probably five official
photographs of the sniper's nest this
sixth floor southeast corner of the
School Book Depository where the boxes
are arranged in four different positions
we don't know today which is the right
position because early on there was a
changing of the holes from the rifle the
the original officers that saw the scene
said that they were laid side by side
there later on we get photographs and
they're scattered like they would be if
it was a both action rifle was used so
these things began early on and had to
involve not all of the Dallas police but
maybe one member you know or somebody in
a position to manipulate this sort of
thing somebody who had access to the
sixth floor of the Texas School Book
Depository was close to Oswald and later
on you know this cover-up it had to go
into the upper echelon some of it I
think was conspiratorial pre-planning
and went to the highest echelons of our
government and some of it was of
expediency is it couldn't there be two
aspects of the cover-up or maybe two
different cover-ups one is the
pre-planned conspiratorial cover-up they
knew they had to cover up evidence
medical ballistic other types of police
type of evidence but then when you get
to the higher level of the Warren
Commission the mass media and all that
that was another cover-up that continues
to today and that may be of a different
nature to totaled it so we're that's
what I mean by that cover by expediency
and I'll talk about when I we talk about
mapping out yeah the first the first one
first and we'll talk about one hanging
at take you to a nice very important
remember in this that in all likelihood
and again this is speculation but I
think it's pretty sound speculation in
all likelihood odds were was never
supposed to leave the Texas School Book
Depository alive had he not left alive
had he been killed there with the
evidence already planted he's dead
never can say a word they killed a
little commie rat open-and-shut case in
this typical of operations of
assassinations where you have somebody
and he's the assassin and you kill him
right it's typical of mother why why
there's a tie how did he have gotten out
there that's furniture obviously he he
didn't do as they supposed he would do
all right you know and when he did and
he made contact with his with his
principal and so they had you know he
had planned to or had to go into effect
had plan one done his job we'd not we
had not had that the extreme cover-up
that we've had to have because of it and
that's a big I think that's a big point
I had not really explored that before
but if he had been they burst in on him
and someone shoots him and his body's
there with the evidence in the window
with a rifle with the boxes with the
bullet then all of the confusion it must
have caused them some anxiety wouldn't
have been necessary and the Ruby and all
the mysterious things that happen that
can only be explained in terms of a
damage control and a prolonged and
increasingly sloppy conspiracy and that
we talked about the cover-up of medical
evidence in our previous program we know
from the two programs previous to that
which you did with us of a lot of
coverup and destruction of evidence by
local police and by the FBI first let's
talk about the local police what type of
cover-up
heard there okay I think some of it
again you would have to have somebody in
a position to be able to buy them so to
speak I think there was cooperation for
instance in in allowing Ruby to have
full run of the police department and be
able to get in the position in which to
to shoot Lee Harvey Oswald to allow the
evidence to be manufactured to be
altered to be destroyed and all of the
things that happened there had to be
some complicity on on the part of that
some of it also I Hank had to be by
expediency and what I mean but let's
just say you're Nick McDonald for
instance and you're a policeman that's
you know several years of service and
suddenly you're cast into the limelight
because you're the one that goes into
the theater and and you slap Boswell up
beside the head and you're the man
responsible for capturing the assassin
of the President of the United States
friend I don't care what you found out
after that you're not going to tell
anybody you know you want him to be
guilty you know this is your moment in
history and I believe a lot of that took
place also if you go back and ask the
policeman right now which we have done
they'll tell you real quickly that they
were told to shut up by number by their
superiors Harriers and number two not
only were they they told to shut up but
the case was taken from the hands of the
Dallas police authorities and
transferred to the FBI contrary to all
laws of the land at that time and how
soon did the FBI come in to take over
all they took over immediately
immediately and large but but soon after
and because one of the things we pointed
out in 1976 and we have this from a farm
report that captain will Fritz
who was in charge of homicide and
robbery and in charge of the
interrogation of Oswald is in
five after the supriya family had been
shown for the first time on nationwide
television
he's eating breakfast with his buddies
the next day and they're talking about
it and he just almost stops in mid bite
and he says well probably all of this is
going to come out now he said but I'll
tell you fellas this is a group that he
always ate with I'll tell you guys that
when the president called me we were
investigating this crime but when the
president called me and told me I had my
man what could I do by that he means
Linda John that he meant Lyndon Johnson
Lyndon Johnson himself called will
creates and told him Lee Harvey Oswald
did it and of course that's what Hoover
began to espouse immediate okay now the
FBI was involved in destruction of
evidence and manipulation of evidence
tampering with evidence and they also
had a hold of Lee Harvey Oswald for a
while and they as I understand it they
didn't even keep transcripts of their
interrogation of Lee Harvey Oswald but
basically the the interrogation Boswell
came under wheel Fritz who was pretty
well renowned for his interrogation of
prisoners and but the FBI were sitting
in on it as I understand were other
intelligence agents Secret Service and
Fritz made the statement that he kept no
notes it's really important he kept no
notes of the interrogation he didn't say
I didn't take any he said I kept no
notes but we've got statements from at
least two people including Oz will
himself when he was asked one time about
a certain thing he says I've already
answered that it's in your notes read
for yourself so we know that we from him
and from from a postal inspector by the
name of
of Harry Holmes who was also present for
what I don't know what a postal
inspector has done it an interrogation
but he was who also mentioned the notes
that were being kept but they've never
turned up and so we don't know what Oz
was saying during during the hours of
his incarceration and before Jack Ruby
shot him but the Dallas Police were not
as derelict I think in the evidentiary
stages as was the the Federal Bureau of
Investigation because some of what they
did you know I find hard to believe even
now Gary one of the big aspects of the
cover-up has to do with his grassy knoll
theory the Zapruder film many
eyewitnesses immediately after the
shooting said that they saw and heard
smoke and bullets coming from the
opposite end of Dealey Plaza from where
Oswald was supposedly shooting him and
the Zapruder film saw Kennedy's head go
in two directions how did they cover up
this grassy knoll theory who was
responsible that was that police FBI or
how did this cover-up take place
basically it had to take place in this
way the Warren Commission totally relied
on the FBI some feeling from the CIA and
some from the Secret Service and other
intelligence agencies and investigative
agencies but basically what the FBI fed
them that's what they use so that the
FBI
you know completely you know they they
didn't say that there were no witnesses
who said the shots but there were no
reliable reports of shots anywhere other
than the sixth floor of the Texas
schoolbook depository one of the one of
the funny things about that is is they
publish steel frames frame by frame of
this approver famine in the Warren
Commission volumes when they get to
frame number 312 and 313 which is the
I'm of the president's fatal head shot
then he takes and reverses those frames
afterwards that way I say he they are
they are reversed and they finally
called and then they have the tendency
is what what you do if you're following
them it has a tendency to completely
negate the backward head movement of the
president upon being shot that's in the
Warren Commission that's when the Warren
Commission is Plan B and he wrote a
letter of course when they found it and
said it was just a printing error all of
those frames and that's the only two
that are out of order so I just kind of
thing all the way through I thought the
FBI had done that they doctored it up
where they were responsible responsible
but they also swallowed a lot of other
evidence didn't they oh yeah okay and
the witnesses they carefully doctor
their use of witnesses I didn't they
family the witnesses that they they
pushed toward the Warren Commission with
those witnesses that bust twisted and
the buttress the their report you know
we we got tunnel vision
I admit that as a as a researcher and
one who's found flaws in it and you know
we tend to tend to go in one direction
but I'm not as bad I don't have the
tunnel vision that they had and if they
would completely ignore all of the it's
amazing the number of witnesses that
said a shot was fired over 50 they were
in Dealey Plaza and a position to hear
and see said the shot came from the
president's right front and that kind of
thing you can't ignore of course the
biggest cover-up right away was the
Warren Commission and that famous that
wonderful memo from that was sent to
them let's see now he's get that mixed
up was it the press secretary sending it
to or somebody's yeah - it was a Terry
can you close tonight love that yeah it
was the assistant attorney general oh
that's right Nicholas Katzenbach writing
to mr. Bill Moyers who was new aide to
the new
President Lyndon Johnson and he wrote
that you know we must miss is a
paraphrase we must say Oswald was the
lone assassin and that we must not let
the American people think that he's not
in other words we must have him right
now in the press as convicted tried and
convicted and no conspiracy exists
whether domestic or foreign and we must
we must get the evidence together in
such a way that there will be no other
possibilities and that this is the only
possibility well it's so so that means
the cover-up was immediate right up at
the top now why somebody had to make
this decision that this had to be
covered up immediately not the highest
level I think that had to come from the
highest level when the Warren Commission
came together and this is just a little
sideline when they came together their
first initial meetings first thing they
got was an outline and a part of the
outline now this is before they've done
any investigation is Oz will ask the
assassin that's one of the major
breakdowns in their outline they've
already before they've investigated and
looked at the case decided that they're
gonna and here's all the items the
subheadings underneath their outline as
to why Iowa was the assassin now that
had to come from the FBI because they're
doing they do dare interim report and
supplemented report to that and said oz
were did it did long when they when the
committee came together they they made
note about John what is what are your
feelings on this it's one thing to have
an assassination of a bunch of people
getting together and killing the
president but then immediately the
highest levels of the government and the
establishment the Warren Commission was
made up of people from the bedrock of
the American political and economic
establishment John J McCloy Allen Dulles
etc and these people immediately say
it's Oswald and that's it and then they
do all this big cover-up I what what are
they trying to cover up well and there's
there is no way that a fair
investigation could have been in fact
conducted by the people around the world
Commission President Johnson selected
that committee obviously with great
advice and input so you start with him
you know we just said that it started
with from the very top president's
supposed to be at the very top what did
he have to gain and lose in terms of the
Kennedy killing and the cover-up now it
is debated about whether or not he might
have engineered it you know so he could
become president and and why not I I
don't see that really
but although God knows his political
career was very very dirty and there are
some bodies lying around but also his
ties with the mob as apparently if you
read David chimes book you know many if
not most of our top political leaders
have mob contacts it may even be a
situation where the mob has such muscle
and influence that you can't really be a
top leader without the connections with
the mob or at least a lace a ferret
relationship with them but in any case
Johnson like the others we mentioned
before is faced with being permanently
eclipsed by John Kennedy Johnson wanted
to be President he could never become
president as long as Kennedy was around
Kennedy's dead he's president I don't
think he necessarily engineered the
killing but he certainly benefited from
it very greatly he could have spent his
entire presidency presiding over an
investigation of the conspiracy to kill
Kennedy or he could get the thing behind
him as quickly as possible and go on
with his life and his presidency in his
place in history now as he did it his
place in history had to do with the
great social revolution in the United
States that he engineered and the
Vietnam War which is tragedy that he
engineered and it had very little to do
with with the Kennedy killing a cursory
sweep it under there under the rug so he
leaped immediately he was
obviously predisposed to leap upon the
lone assassin get the thing behind him
and go on with his life you go to others
allan dulles to put him on that
committee he was obviously a mortal
enemy of John Kennedy he was the person
in the CIA the famous director who
really was responsible for the Bay of
Pigs fiasco even to the detail of
arranging to be in Puerto Rico giving a
lecture when the landing happened so
that he would have plausible deniability
which meant he wasn't there to persuade
the president to do this or that he was
hiding out down in Puerto Rico and he
got fired
you know his place in history to mind
you had been involved in great
manipulations during and after World War
two he had a great sense of his own role
in history behind the scenes perhaps but
nevertheless making and breaking
presidents all over the world and he's
fired by Kennedy and some humiliation at
the end of his long and distinguished
career to put him on that commission
what chance are you going to have of him
vigilantly investigating who killed the
president especially if some of his own
former CIA people were involved as they
clearly were Gerald Ford others on a
committee were promised wrong historic
allies and protectors of the FBI and as
we said before J Edgar Hoover had a long
lifetime association with organized
crime and the FBI director who gave the
orders to focus on a lone assassin in
some ways if the cover-up seems so crass
and flagrant and yet if you understand
the workings of the government they they
generally come up with party lines I
mean the President or Henry Kissinger
when he dominated the government would
put out the word and this is the policy
and everybody else even if they knew it
wasn't true that was the line and
everybody sort of takes up on and the
Admirals the generals had passed the
word down in the Bethesda Medical Center
and Walter Reed Hospital that you know
what people better not speak they
wouldn't have to be calling on the phone
to the Admiral for example saying be
sure that the autopsy is done this way
in this way and this way to make the
cover-up work they wouldn't present it
that way at all they would
be saying look we want to make sure that
this Lona sighs they've already caught
the killer we want to make sure they're
not a lot of wild rumors and people
agitating around the nation and Johnson
gave them some useful cover stories he
said if I investigate this thing
vigilantly we may have to go to war with
Russia implying that the Russians might
have done it
so the general is calling down to the
Admiral to the people down below saying
let's keep this thing under control
let's be mature about it they've already
caught the killer it's obviously this
coming nut Lee Harvey Oswald now make
sure everybody doesn't go hog-wild and
keep the lid on those doctors down there
I want I don't want them shooting off
their mouths and in a military
establishment and with the discipline
they have that would be sufficient for a
whole lot of people to say aye aye sir
here's the word yes sir and let's and
then of course they had to have someone
a little more cynical than that to
manipulate the photographs that you know
to put care in places where there wasn't
here before and cover up wounds that so
they I mean they literally cut it's in
the high treason but of the head of the
president you can see where they added
in an effective to pay to cover up where
the wear wounds actually existed this
kind of thing the whole government
agreeing and then the establishment
agreeing the press agreeing okay here's
the line this is the way it is the
president said the Warren Commission
said and it all falls kind of naturally
into place except in this case I mean
they've done it hundreds and hundreds of
times with lesser things the necessity
of our going into the Vietnam War that
blew up in their faces later on but it
worked for a while in the nation marched
off to war again they did it very
successfully with Ronald Reagan as he
was president trying to make him appear
as a wise benign president when in fact
he was mentally defective he couldn't
think straight but they all agreed that
he was the president it was his policies
and then packaged him and sold him to
the country now there is a massive mass
media cover-up in this too they went
right along with it to this day the
establishment media say you're giving
the party line of the
Warren Commission now how could they
have been controlled and fit into this
frame well 80% of our news in this
country is quoting the president or
quoting some figure quoting the Warren
Commission this is how they maintain
power in the hands of the people in
power what are the voices the
spokespeople and in power the news is
that in giving his speech today
President Bush said such and so it's not
considered to be good form to write and
he was lying through his teeth
throughout the whole thing and everybody
was laughing and giggling because it
couldn't possibly be true no the news
story is the president said such and so
and then what he said and then senator
so-and-so in the Warren Commission there
was article after article when the
people on the Commission itself were
speaking out and they were all saying
and J Edgar Hoover statements and Bill
Moyers statements and the assistant
attorney general statements and all the
others saying it's clearly a lone
assassin so the media is reporting that
now obviously the media one would dream
that the media could take a more
aggressive position and put big
headlines saying flagrant cover-up with
what people are lying all over the place
but the rules of journalism that the
owners of the media have established are
that that would be irresponsible
journalism this is where you get into
the books you know manufacturing consent
Chomsky's book on the subject or
inventing reality michael parenthese
book on the subject how they make
believe and then make the nation believe
their make-believe it's irresponsible
journalism for the newspapers to take
the lead and say what happened they
believe their role or they maintain it
their role is to announce or to repeat
to the public what the leaders say
happened on the editorial page they
obviously could do a better job they
would defend themselves I'm quite sure
by saying oh we ran lots of articles
about other theories and other
possibilities and we ran lots of op-ed
piece is expressing doubt about this and
the other and they go back and show you
the articles but it still doesn't carry
weight until you get some front-page
story saying senator so-and-so says this
is a flagrant cover-up Kennedy was
killed sloppy investigation massive
cover-up afoot and an immediate didn't
see its responsibility to do that it saw
its responsibility to
participate in the cover story there's
another aspect of this to that from my
studies if you look to see who the media
moguls were at this time and who the top
people in American power structure like
head of Chase Manhattan Bank the head of
Ford Foundation the head of the CIA you
find that they are all interlocked with
each other they are involved in
organizations such as the Council on
Foreign Relations the Bilderbergers they
are in a lot of the same elite social
clubs the head of the time life was a
man who was a very important person at
the top of the American power structures
a CD Jackson so it'd be very easy for
these people to see each other
informally or call each other up knowing
each other and their attitudes on
keeping control of the government and
the economic system it would be very
easy for them to coordinate say hey that
we got to do this and then they would
just take it from there Wayne Smith you
know is a distinguished professor at
Johns Hopkins is formally the State
Department's representative in Cuba and
resigned in 82 in protest of Reagan's
policies lifetime career as a diplomat
visa via the u.s. and Cuba and not long
ago during the summer when I was reading
some of these books he we were talking
on the phone he said that they're
feeling back then at the time of the
killing was that the nation was simply
not ready for the awful truth that the
fabric of society couldn't tolerate it
couldn't accept it and and then he said
he wasn't sure they were necessarily
wrong given the circumstances back then
all the way his position is that now
enough time has gone by that we should
investigate he would like to see a full
honest investigation at the present time
my answer to him maybe I'm a tourist
maybe I'm still in a perverse way naive
as I was naive when the CIA was using me
but I don't buy that even if it would
tear the nation apart from top to bottom
if that's what's if you have such
cynicism that they can kill the
president and stuff it down the public's
throat
and go on about their lives then we need
to tear the society apart from top to
bottom and shake it apart and get some
sense of law and order what reality of
order can there be in a society that is
that cynical
you know how scuse me go ahead John well
I you know I said that and he he did not
disagree with and he's certainly working
now to get an investigation but if
someone like him would clearly
understand their thinking back then well
it's it's truly gruesome but the nation
just wouldn't be ready to deal with a
cover-up that kills our president better
to pull together and keep you know
nationalism going and everything Wow
I think every time I see the big dogs
say something like that I saw during
Watergate etc oh it'll tear this country
apart of we have an investigation on
what they're really saying is that the
American people would find out too much
about how the American political and
economic system really work and who
controls it and how and who benefits and
if this window were to open up and
people were to see the way things really
would happen they would be quite angry
so in the Kennedy case they would see
how the CIA was operating as Lyndon
Johnson later set a damn murder
incorporated in Latin America they would
see the relationships between the
establishment people and the mob and
organized crime and drugs and they would
see the all of these unsavory things
which the American people are not aware
of and if there were a true
investigation of this these things would
come out and they might lose control if
there had been a true investigation of
the kennedy killing George Bush's
policies today would be different if he
would be an office in fact his his
double-sided cover story about a war on
drugs while his own personal and his own
staff's involvement with major drug
dealers he of course blithely ignores in
a major media blithely ignores even
though they have previously published
these things they've now agreed it's
okay
what what's happening there one can
surmise is
carry over to the Kennedy assassination
is this is the Mafia after all or forms
of it that are smuggling the drugs and
you really are never going to go after
them you know you don't want to get
yourself bumped up it's much better to
play ball and all the balances take
place and that way you don't get
yourself assassinated in fact there's
even a more sinister aspect to this
cover-up than we've gone into so far and
that is the amount of people that were
killed or mysteriously died who were
either involved in the conspiracy or had
evidence and testimony that went against
the lone assassin theory Gary when did
the mysterious deaths so to speak begin
with the cover-up when did witnesses
begin dying let us say under mysterious
circumstances and how broad did this
mysterious death but I think it probably
have to start with Lee Oswald at least
arrest and it goes from there it started
immediately and it continues even today
there's no way to put a number figure to
it but you can let's just take two or
three George de Mohrenschildt who was oz
was best friend in Dallas a very
influential Russian immigrant and a very
smart intelligent man befriended the
Oswald's he had French intelligence
connections button dating back into
World War two did some very strange
things had some strange connections to
some very high-ranking people in fact
was in the Intelligence Agency
headquarters in mid 1963 with a colonel
and a man from down in Haiti a very
important bankers down there but that's
a store you know different story three
hours before he was to talk to a Senate
investigator looking into the Kennedy
assassination
he had already made contact with him set
up the apartment he takes a shotgun puts
it in his mouth and blows his brains out
that's what we're told and I'm supposing
that that's what happened
but the key is it was because of the
Kennedy assassination
Sam Giancana was one of these with
operation Mongoose one of the organized
crime figures who had already was
telling the Senate and was being called
before them one more time and late in
the night he is shot in the basement of
his home as he's fixing a breakfast
obviously for himself and whoever this
friend quote-unquote is that's there
with him who shoots him once in the back
and then I understand shoots him seven
times in the mouth as he lays there
dying meaning just the boys point
Giancana
associate in this operation Mongoose
which was the Castro assassination
attempts was a fella by the name of John
Roselli you people have heard this story
but but it's very important he's been
talking about all of the things
surrounding the Castro attempts and the
John Kennedy assassination and suddenly
he ends up floating up out of Key
Biscayne Florida and a 55-gallon drum
he's been cut to pieces and stucked into
it and left there for dead this goes on
and on and on there are witnesses in
Healy Plaza - ruby associates and
friends - organized crime figures - hi
CIA people how many oh I have no idea
it's you know it's been calculated by
some to be in the 40s and 50s and some
by some own up in past 200 I don't think
you can actually set high treason book
is one of the better recent books let's
talk about some of these recent - both
yeah this would this would definitely be
useful this book high treason by Robert
Groden Harrison Livingstone they list 49
people as I count them they don't have
number but I went Albert if I didn't
miss when it was 49 by name explaining
what their association with the killing
what what they knew and the timing of
their killing and then they mentioned a
couple places of seven here and seven
there that also were killed without
naming them these forty-nine killings as
they describe them they're imaginative
all kinds of deaths some of them
apparently suicide some of them
improbable suicides car crashes
shootings bludgeonings you name it they
could be done by anyone I see a lot of
mob involvement but this is frankly
because I know so much about the the
Jack Ruby's involvement in the killing
and other mob figures in and around the
killing and so you know the mob was
there and then you think of these things
yeah that sounds like the mob might very
well have done that if it had been a
killing in a situation where there was
no possible mob involvement I would not
have felt uncomfortable and believing
that these were engineered by people
like the CIA's OPA Mongoose people are
people working out of the Pentagon
there's nothing special about them it's
just different ways you can knock people
off trying to keep it well I say trying
to keep it from being too flagrant lots
of my very late cria
getting onto these books healthy oh
we've got so many in such good ones
coming out now and it makes it in 1980
reading Anthony summers book clearly you
could only conclude from that that there
was a conspiracy what was the name of
that book ah conspiracy oh okay his book
conspiracy and he's but he pulls his
punches sorry but he pulls up at the end
he won't deal with the killed witnesses
and and he won't deal really with
projecting as to who might have done the
conspiracy who was responsible for it
and under what circumstances now there
were some books out then Gary's book a
cover-up did deal with you know who
might have done with the conspiracy and
the conspiracy and killing and the
cover-up
we we had a kind of a dearth for a while
books coming out they've been lots of
books on the assassination I'm sure but
major books coming out recently we've
had several come out that that really
bring a lot of this together in great
detail and just to mention these for the
benefit of the the viewers there's a
book best Evidence by David liftin and
this one doesn't reach any conclusions
but it just goes meticulously over the
evidence showing all the discrepancies
in the Warren Commission's presentation
of things very powerful without leading
you anywhere in in the in a picture this
book reasonable doubt by hurt you can
show it to the camera the first half of
this book I found to be just absolutely
excellent as he presents the the
evidence in in Dallas around the killing
that could not fit a lone assassin
theory the second half of the book I
felt like it drifts into things that a
much less specific a little harder to
follow and thereby less convincing just
in the last year we have two books that
have come out that really quite
fascinating a little bit of unfortunate
controversy around them but they even
that may stimulate interest and make it
worthwhile but you have David shines
book which presents the strong case this
is contract on America and it's sold
zillions of copies fortunately zebra
Press published last year where he
focuses on the extent of the mobs
involvement in the killing but also with
top US political leaders this is an
excellent book to get a vision of how
much and influence and how vigorous and
how energetic the mob is and was in that
killing unfortunately it's a weakness in
his book I think he just doesn't deal
with the sea-ice presence very much in
the killing now we've corresponded with
him since then and it is not that he
believes the CIA was not presence he
does but he was just investigating the
mobs you know involvement in it and well
perhaps a better choice of wording he
might have said that he might have come
out and said you know the CI was also
involved but I focused on the mom and
the mob overlaps and
the CIA then you have the garrison book
which goes the opposite and says it was
the CIA and doesn't say much about the
mob and Garrison's book is another
excellent book as Jim Garrison from New
Orleans he was the district attorney who
investigated this thing who engineered
some some trial tried to get people
prosecuted tried to prosecute Clay Shaw
himself was put on trial and both of
those trials were futile the people were
not convicted he or show and then
evidence came out much later that he
probably would have won his case if he
had had the full evidence against Shaw
that came out years after Shaw died one
of the forty nine people unfortunately
controversy that surrounds garrison as
he was flailed by the major media and
lots of stories were circulated that he
was associated with the mob he was a
district attorney in New Orleans for the
mob ran things and Hetal Marcelo had so
much energy and control and he's of
course said that they were just out to
get him because he was exposing their
activities unfortunately for his case
for his credibility he has a shot in
this book to clarify his position visa V
the mob and he doesn't even in this book
when he had a chance to say here's why I
was not involved with the mob he instead
he says that Jack Ruby may have run some
errands for the mob oh my gosh oh yeah
and he says at the end he paths brushes
off mob involvement at other times he
said that in New Orleans he's found no
evidence of Carlos Marcello running
things or dominating things and you
could not be district attorney in New
Orleans and not know of the extent of
Marcellus activities maybe he doesn't
want to be assassinated well it could
very well be and now now the shine he
gets a little stickier than that Cheyne
writes in his book that garrison has mob
ties and has been seen having brother
with Carlos Marcelo's brothers having
dinner having breakfast and dinner sorry
with Carlos Marcello's brothers after
Marcelo was in prison
and this would you know imply in it and
also citing a time he went a country
with them to some villa in Louisiana to
meet with them now we've tracked this
down and asked shame about his source on
that and he says his sources are
impeccable but they're announced he
can't reveal them for the evidence of
garrison dining with the Marcella
brothers that's unfortunate because to
make an assertion like that it would be
awfully nice if you had some
documentation you could share with
readers to help them a photograph or
something to help them judge and he
doesn't have that so he's asking us to
take it on faith that he has
unimpeachable sources of that
information he nevertheless I think
these are two excellent books but
they're just looking at different parts
of the elephant one of them showing the
mob involvement is is just an excellent
piece of work and Garrison's book is
fascinating and his conclusions are very
strong although he just will not address
the mob issue this is what brings us to
the the best book that we have out
recently is high treason by Robert
Groden and Harrison Livingston
conservatory Press published in 1989
they put it all together now they really
try to beat it to death they overwrite
it they make a point and then they
repeated five times to make it very
clear what they're trying to say and
given all the obligation and confusion
around the assassination I find this
effective in dealing with this subject
it's it's a well-written book to this
purpose and they put it all together
they show the mobs involvement the CIA's
involvement the military's involvement
they show the photographs that were
altered they discuss how the body was
was altered and changed from one casket
to the next all kinds of details in it
and they do reach conclusions which
again Anthony summers avoided doing they
project as we've done in this show in
the previous one as to how it must have
been done and who must have been
involved and they conclude as we have
that that the CIA engineered the killing
itself the ambush and a cover-up was
the result of a broad conspiracy if you
will cooperation between the FBI and the
military and the CIA and the Warren
Commission and the White House they tend
to if you'll permit me they tend to
guild the Kennedys in a way that I would
not do they really idolize them and
tribute to them no evil and no
remarkable weaknesses and what role do
they attribute to the mob in there he
didn't mention that analysis in the high
treason book it deals with the CIA's
involvement and with the mobs
involvement and shows the relationship
between them they get that right because
no one previously had explored the way
that they also go into the operation
Mongoose story yeah they go into it
although yeah they go into it
convincingly they could go into greater
detail they could explore it further but
they go into it and it's a very
convincing book and I what what do you
think there's a there's another book
that ought to be mentioned there and
that's John Davis's book called mafia
kingpin and it concerns called US
Marshall oh the New Orleans mafia
chieftain and and takes the same
position is shine to some extent but
more more detailed more evidence and
very convincing in that area high
treason Robert Groden it ought to be
made known he is the same Robert Groden
that did all of the fine work on the
Abraham Zapruder film the original
optically enhanced and and had the
intestinal fortitude to to get on the
Geraldo Rivera show and show it on
national television under threat of
lawsuit and everything else you can
think of and showed it to the American
people and was a great boost to you know
the American public's awareness of what
was going on here what extent does it
correspond with your own research I
would want any different take on it
I would point out that that he brings
out some new evidence in it he he's one
of the first to publish by the way the
new best evidence book as well as his
publishes for the first time the black
and white photographs of the president's
autopsy a lot of people are going to
trial that's just terrible to do that
the only reason it's done the only
reason it's done is because what the
evidence shows from those autopsy
photographs makes a liar out of the
previous investigations one more time
you should show the viewers the J Edgar
Hoover book secrecy and power oh it's a
book that's excellent it's it's
restrained it they pull their punches
they don't talk about the fact that J
Edgar Hoover stole a million dollars
from the American taxpayer he was a
thief but they do make it clear and you
read that in conjunction with a contract
on America and you get the extent to
which the Mafia is involved with our
leaders J Edgar Hoover a lifetime
involvement with organized crime
while deny denying that it existed in
the United States and Lyndon Johnson and
Richard Nixon's involvement with
organized crime and even the Kennedys
sort of alter ego involvement with them
although they were they were after them
they also had involvements with them
sharing mistresses sharing mistresses
for example Gary we've seen on TV uncle
Walter Cronkite on PBS coming out with a
program that was absolute whitewash of
the Warren Commission and they didn't
look at anything else they just tried to
make it appear credible and then the
Jack Anderson had a rather strange thing
where he said it was Castro who did it
and the reason they did the cover-up was
because if if the American people knew
there was Castro that they would have
been
aroused and up in arms and they would
have won the United States to invade and
destroy Cuba and then that would have
brought to Russia into the war and then
we'd had World War three did you see
these - yes and of course that's not
newest to us it's been one of the one of
the things that's been put forth through
for a number of years I reject it just
for the simple fact that number one I
don't think we were anywhere near that
and there could never have been a time
that I think that Castro would have felt
comfortable in killing the President of
the United States and so I reject that
and I certainly don't think that there
was enough to that for him to have the
power or his causing that to be done in
there and he had the power to cover up a
cause to have the cover-up perpetrated
for all of these years here getting back
this high treason do they speculate
there and who the actual hit team was to
the extent that you do where you point
to some of the people that could have
been actually involved in the
assassination do they go that far now
later not and you know and when we point
to some of the people that we point to
them because we have evidence that
causes us to point to those for instance
on our last show that we did together we
we looked at a man by the name of
Charles Houston who's a well-known
assassin hitman and who had already
confessed to not only killing a federal
judge in San Antonio Texas but also he
said at the same time I also killed
President Kennedy others have confirmed
the fact that he was not lying
and that he has been for a number of
years even as a young man he was about
25 in 1963 even as a young man one of
the top qualified assassins in the
United States so I don't find it unusual
if a guy says he'd uh you know does
something I think it ought to be looked
at the media he said so what Ohan and
there's evidence that he was in Dallas
well there is some evidence in that we
have photographs of some people Rams
being arrested and one of them is the
spitting image of the man in fact we've
shown photographs of him and of the man
being arrested and two two independent
forensic anthropologists people who
testify doctors who testify in court on
matters of facial resemblance and they
said that there was a 90 to 95 percent
probability that the two men were in the
same so you have one of the most
detailed accounts of the Kennedy
assassination yet did any of the media
call on you during the night 225
anniversary celebrations last fall I
didn't see you on the [ __ ]
constantly but I I got cut there I got
the cutting room floor most nights in
the about three and a half minutes we
have left that's not much to make time
to make a conclusion but the satirist
Paul Krassner said we saw him say that
well we've had all these political
assassinations and the survivors now say
they have a mandate but Kennedy of
course wasn't the last political
assassination you had Karen Silkwood you
had RFK Bobby Kennedy you had attempted
kill George Wallace and Martin Luther
King was assassinated so it appears that
the political assassination has been
alive and well in the United States and
apparently the people saw that they
could get away with this another either
that this group the did this conspiracy
or other people say hey it works and we
can get away with it why not do it Kerry
do you see this Kennedy assassination as
a coup d'etat as one of the books on the
subject indicates it was an attempt by a
small group of people literally to seize
power
as they weren't in agreement with the
direction the Kennedy was moving I
definitely do and I think you can look
at history and it'll bear that out the
the policies that President Kennedy was
moving toward and putting into operation
started changing that almost at very day
and we were never the same and going
back to that day it would be like
turning a page in history to histoy
they're already seeing that you know one
of these days I hope we'll learn the
history lesson that this is saying to us
they did do it in 1963 they did cover it
up and when I say they I wish I knew all
the particulars involved we don't yet
and but they have continued to sell it
to us until the people today say what's
the use what can we do about it we're
just one or we're just ten or we're just
25 I would urge you to say you know
we're still a very viable force in this
country when we rise up and speak and
say we want something done we're not
through with this and well these days
history will confirm that president john
f kennedy was killed by a conspiracy
founded within his own government but
the perpetrators after a long period of
time were finally convicted brought to
justice what in a couple of minutes or
so would you evaluate this whole
situation of political assassinations
just to simplify the whole thing in all
of my readings about the CI Secret Wars
and activities certainly the the thing
that gives you the the bottom line of
the cynicism is the Kennedy killing that
they would engineer a killing because
they're not content with the electoral
process and assassinate our president
and stuff it down the public's throat
the cover story and get by with it so
that no one is prosecuted the cynicism
of doing this in broad daylight in front
of the eyes of the world if you will
much says it all doesn't it